We've come to the last coding exercise in this course.
Now that you've got your conference central application up and
running, I'm going to show you a couple of things you'll
need to do if you want to write a mobile
application to use your conference API. You're going to need to
give your mobile app a client ID. Regardless of whether
you're building an Android app or an IOS app, you
need a client ID. And just like with the web application,
you create the client ID in the developer console. We're also going to
generate the client libraries for your conference API so that you can include
those libraries in your mobile application. But what your mobile application
chooses to do with the Conference API, well, that's up to you. Come on then!